[Music]
there was a rocket attack on the u.s air
base in bagram afghanistan this morning
nato said there were no reported
casualties or damage to the airfield
but it's the latest reminder the u.s is
still engaged in the longest war
in its history the closing chapter of
the war in afghanistan is also the
subject of a new book the last platoon
by bing west a marine and one of the
world's great combat writers
if people have forgotten about the war
and the madness of everything else
this year west is here to remind you
those who put their lives on the line
have not
it's one thing to be in a fire fight at
20 years old
you'd think it's another if you're four
times that age
but at 80 being west keeps going back
all i wanted to do was just tell the
reader
what it's all about every single day for
20 years
what our grunts were doing in
afghanistan bing west's war service
started
in 1966 in vietnam where he conducted
more than a hundred combat patrols
he later wrote a vietnam classic the
village
the true story of one marine squad that
fought for 495 straight days
half died the village is one of west's
10 books
the new one is the last platoon about
the endgame
in afghanistan i think that it was
properly titled that i
called the book the last platoon because
we don't have any more platoons out
there we have some good
cia operatives and some good special
forces
but no we're no longer out in the
countryside
fighting every day the way we used to
should we still have platoons there no
in my judgment no the last platoon
is fiction but it doesn't read like it
it's one of the most powerful things
we've opened this year
allowing us to look at a crushing
battlefield through the eyes of marine
captain
diego cruz your protagonist in this book
um
he's vulnerable and he's i think he's
very relatable
and and complicated what were you trying
to
to get across when you when you built
him well i was trying to tell the story
of what happens if you are in charge of
a small platoon
40 people and you're given a mission
and you know that if you achieve certain
things you'll be promoted
but as you start to get into the fight
you wonder
is my promotion worth the risks that i'm
taking on not taking
from a president of the united states
down to the troops on the ground
west pulls together a cast of characters
informed by a career
serving his country including a stint as
one of ronald reagan's assistant
secretaries of defense
it's mostly been non-fiction for you i
think it's just the second
second novel why fiction here because i
wanted to bring in different points of
view
without causing people to you know say
bing i'm not gonna ever speak to you
again so
i think any novelist will tell you these
are composites of real people
yeah some of these characters are thinly
veiled
yes get yourself out boys
was an rpg incoming here comes another
one
this is america's longest war 20 years
on a trillion dollars
what have we got we have a big mistake
in terms of policy
the policy level of saying that we could
turn afghanistan
into a democratic nation that was a step
entirely too far
we could have done that but only if we
stayed like we did in south korea for
70 years and we weren't going to do that
west says by now the heroin trade
has decimated afghanistan in his words
the country is
hurtling headfirst into the 9th century
he has been relentless for years in
criticizing one of the central tenets of
counterinsurgency
the young troops should be directed to
win hearts and minds
in addition to firefights
[Music]
he insists it's a fool's errand which
doesn't mean he has any less reverence
for what warriors on the front lines do
accomplish
it's why he keeps going back to see them
we've heard from some of these 19 year
old kids who say they have a tough time
keeping up with you
at 75 or 80. that's pretty cool yes
i suppose but i do have a little
confession to make that
they have to wear very heavy flak
jackets
i learned how to kind of use a flak
jacket that didn't really have all the
stuff in it so they were carrying more
gear than i was
and often in a firefight they'd ask hey
sir do you want a weapon and my answer
was i think
a weapon now i have to carry 14 more
pounds and i keep saying to them look
if ever i need a weapon there'll be
plenty around
because you have screwed up the last
platoon is bing west's goodbye
to a war that has cost more than a
trillion dollars yes
but more importantly a reminder of the
greater toll more than 2300 lives lost
and tens of thousands of others that
will never be the same
we went on the wrong track but that
doesn't mean that our troops didn't do
their very best
it's just that we were going down the
wrong road
the trump administration has been
anxious to get out of afghanistan that
is now an issue the biden incoming biden
administration
will inherit but think about i mean 20
years
right i don't think go right just to say
he paints these really complex portraits
it sounds like of like the protagonist
he's he's he's i mean bing has the
experience and he has the writing skill
it's really
a fun a fun read an interesting read
fascinating read
because he does such a great job and he
has that background
all right jeff great piece thank you